a menos de una semana para el día de
acción de gracias el aeropuerto
internacional de los ángeles ya presenta
mucho movimiento con unas
hospitalizaciones que han aumentado en
cerca de un 50% en las últimas dos
semanas los centros para el control y
prevención de enfermedades hacen un
llamado a no viajar de próximo jueves
la recomendación es cenar con aquellos
que viven bajo el mismo techo en espacio
abierto guardando el distanciamiento
social y con tapabocas en este panorama
son cada vez más los estados que adoptan
la reimposición de restricciones
california implantará desde el sábado a
un toque de queda nocturno y que
aplicará para el 94% de sus 40 millones
de habitantes mientras tanto en
washington el equipo de trabajo del
gobierno para combatir la pandemia
volvió a comparecer con el presidente
dando trump como gran ausente
con los medicamentos y las terapias y
muy pronto con la vacuna disponible en
eeuu nunca he estado más preparado que
hoy para combatir este virus
- calmado se mostró el presidente electo
joe biden quien habló con algunos
gobernadores e hizo un llamado al
ejecutivo para que colabore en snow
excuse y no hay excusa para no compartir
la información y dejarnos comenzar la
planificación choques de política en
medio de una pandilla que deja más de
250.000 fallecidos en la unión americana
y a puertas de la temporada navideña por
lo menos para acción de gracias' estos
robots en bedford massachusetts se
encargarán de empacar unas donaciones y
así ahorrarle esa tarea a los
voluntarios de mayor edad y reducir su
exposición al virus